c'est dans le quotidien que les
étudiants ont choisi de s'adresser très
directement au président de l'université
stas gens qui une lettre ouverte dans
laquelle ils disent refuser de regarder
le pôle martinique être dépouillé sans
réagir
sa menace non seulement président
s'adresse à l'ensemble de la population
martiniquaise parce que parce qu'on se
rend compte qu'en fait les enjeux ne
sont pas que pour faire les enjeux sont
globales pour l'ensemble du territoire
martiniquais
il ne concerne pas uniquement les
étudiants c'est vraiment l'avenir de la
masse et qui est en train de se jouer
aujourd'hui il n'ya pas uniquement
l'université de guadeloupe et de
martinique de l'université des antilles
et en divisant les deux nous ont plus de
financement en divisant les deux nous
aurons qu'un moignon d'université avec
de l'autre côté une université complète
c'est une injustice
réunis en assemblée générale sur le
campus la communauté universitaire est
vent debout contre la décision de
transférer près de 7 millions d'euros de
masse salariale de schoelcher vers
pointe à pitre
l'autonomie du pôle martinique serait
clairement menacé nous assistons
aujourd'hui à une tragédie parce qu'il
s'agit bien de dépouiller un pôle
universitaire au profit de notre pôle
universitaire et ça c'est une admission
la majorité des administrateurs
martiniquais de l'ue a donc décidé
aujourd'hui de boycotter le conseil
d'administration qui devait entériner
cette nouvelle répartition budgétaire
pour les professeurs mobilisés ce qu'ils
ont malgré tout participer aux votes
sont des traîtres
je suis chine pas seulement en tant
qu'enseignant mais surtout entre le
martiniquais
j'estime que pour ce pays il faut faire
des choses il faut développer ce pays ce
n'est pas comme ça pour développer ce
pays et que bien évidemment lors de six
de ses conseils il se trouve qu'il ya
des martiniquais qui votent à l'encontre
de l'intérêt de la martinique
c'est simple c'était supporter une
colère entendu parler politique
la ctm qui est représenté au conseil
d'administration de l'université était
également aux côtés des professeurs et
des étudiants ce matin pour la
conseillère exécutive chargée de
l'enseignement supérieur on assiste à
une dérive
la présidence guadeloupéen à un moment
donné il faut savoir dire stop à l'
escalade
nous avons eu à subir la procédure
concernant l'offre de formation et de
recherche pour le pôle martinique
il y a eu la question de la répartition
des moyens aujourd'hui on en vient à la
question dans la campagne des emplois a
priori en faveur du pôle guadeloupe je
crois qu'il faut avoir un message très
clair et dire là on veut aller
une question qui devra trouver réponse
elle ne concerne pas uniquement l'avenir
du campus mais également celui de nos
enfants